hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in book five of the brothers karamazov
in the chapter entitled the grand
inquisitor
ivan mazoff puts into that character's
mouth
a speech that he gives about how
christ could have made human beings
happy but failed to do so
instead offering them a freedom that
they can't really
use in any correct way and
how the grand inquisitor and his
colleagues are going to
fix that mistake they're going to
improve upon the divine plan
and it's framed in terms of the three
temptations talked about in the gospel
narrative
where christ is out in the desert
fasting for
40 days and nights the devil comes to
him and
tempts him in three ways all of which
christ rejects
the third and the in in some respect
most inclusive
the most encompassing of these
temptations
is that the the devil shows him all
of the kingdoms on earth and says these
can all be
yours and christ rejects that
so the third temptation is a temptation
about you could say rulership
and so here it's it's framed
largely in terms of of that the
other two were framed slightly
differently than the the gospel
narrative it's not
producing bread for yourself it's
producing bread for others
and then there's the whole discussion
about miracle and mystery in this case
it's pretty straightforward
you could rule or not rule and
there's a perennial problem if
one doesn't take power when it's offered
somebody
else is going to make use of that or it
will be
an anarchy of people turning against
each other
and that is in fact what the grand
inquisitor says that
christ could have avoided but
chose not to and so
christ could have provided for all of
human needs
all of our needs ranging from those of
the bodily matters like
food and hunger all the way up to all of
our spiritual needs as well
and so the grand inquisitor tells him
um i have a secret to tell you we're not
with you we're with we're with him the
devil
that's our secret for a long time eight
centuries already
we have not been with you but with him
exactly eight centuries ago we took from
him what you
so indignantly rejected the last gift he
offered you when he showed you
all the kingdoms of earth we took rome
and the sword of caesar from him and
proclaimed ourselves
soul rulers of the earth the only rulers
though we have not yet succeeded in
bringing our cause
to its full conclusion and bringing
their cause to the full conclusion
is what he's going to map out a little
bit later but we should ask ourselves
well
wait wait a second 800 years ago what
are we talking about the constantine was
much earlier than that
and that's the usual reference point for
christians is it not
when you know things went from being a
nice innocent
happy church to being under the rule
of the terrible emperor and there's a
lot of you know nonsense there that that
has been
uh long since invented and we don't have
to worry about that but we're curious
though well what is what happened 800
years
earlier this is in the 1500s so
back it up about 700 years what do we
have
charlemagne and the establishment
of the holy roman empire but wait a
second
who was in charge of the holy roman
empire wasn't it
the emperor himself or was it the pope
and there were back and forth struggles
throughout the rest of
the middle ages over precisely that
question
so you could say well maybe we're
talking about
a religious authority maybe we're
talking about a political authority
maybe we're talking about a fusion of
both maybe we're talking about alliances
that doesn't matter so much the point is
that
the church in this this
narrative here had become so intensely
political
and was looking not just for the
spiritual
benefits of the flock but for
other benefits instead so
what's going on here he tells us that
if you you know why did you reject this
this gift had you accepted that third
counsel the mighty spirit
you would have furnished all that human
beings seek on earth
someone to bow down to somebody to take
over their conscience and a means for
uniting everyone
into something human beings want things
to be universal
to have unity what would the
result be this is a very wonderful
phrase
one common concordant
incontestable ant hill
ants have been viewed as sort of the
social creatures par excellence since
the time
of aristotle where he talked about them
as being
in some quasi sense political creatures
in that they have organization right and
if you think about an ant hill
you don't get a lot of ants like
carrying signs around saying
we want representation no they all do
their business and actually the more
that we know about ants
over the years through through modern
science we we know that they're in
like one big hive mind in some respect
carrying out all of these things through
chemical traces
and genetics and you know they're quite
adaptable there's very interesting
things that happen
with them but they you can't say that
there's a lot of freedom in an anvil
right so freedom has been taken away
and one common one thing
covering the entire earth so instead of
there being a number of different
anthills and ant colonies
one vast colony with everybody
on the same page this leads us to the
concordant
right what does it mean to have concord
that's harmony that's everybody's wills
being united or being compatible in a
certain way
and then incontestable that's an
interesting phrase right there
there is no other earthly power that
would be able to stand up against this
there's literally no other space to go
to
where you would raise a rebellion or
carve out perhaps a space of
free thought that actually mattered for
yourself
so he says the need for universal union
is this third and last
torment of human being mankind in its
entirety is always urine to arrange
things so they must be universal
and he gives some interesting examples
here there have been many great nations
with great histories the higher these
nations stood the unhappier they were
why they were more strongly aware than
others
of the need for a universal union of
mankind
dostoevsky in his time gives the
examples of great conquerors
such as tamerlane genghis khan right
we're looking at the mongols
and the mongols did in fact control
quite a vast empire
we could think of so many other world
empires as well
we could think about things a little bit
closer to our own time
think about the nazis and the wish to
have a thousand-year reich
that would eventually dominate the world
and were there as in you know science
fiction
and alternate history stories other
worlds for them to conquer
they would want to dominate those worlds
as well we could think about
the soviet union and its attempt to
control
as much as possible we could think about
america
and its need to police nearly every
corner of the world in the name of
security
we could think of all sorts of examples
of these universal
empires all of which end up
disintegrating
falling apart not making their people
genuinely
happy even though they're striving after
something that would
make people happy and he says that
if christ had accept caesar's purple
that is rulership he would have founded
a universal kingdom and granted
universal peace
and so we we took caesar's sword
and in taking it of course we rejected
you and followed him
the devil and he says it's not all done
right now there's going to be
centuries of problems of
in fact horrors of freedom as this
edifice of the tower of babel is rebuilt
as new kingdoms come
and go and fight each other he talks
about there will be centuries of the
lawlessness of free reason
of their science and anthro anthropo
veggie right which means eating human
beings
feasting on human beings using human
beings
as meat he says for having begun to
build their tower of babel without us
they will end in
anthropo faji right and
why is this the case well there's really
several different reasons
one is that the you know
free reasons science all that leads to
technology which is going to
make things even deadlier create new
possibilities
it's also the case that the grand
inquisitor is looking ahead and this is
where you know
very existentialist text the you know
sciences were supposed to
solve everything and in the 19th century
there was this great dream that many
people still have today in the 21st
century
that you know if we just get scientific
about things all the problems of life
will fall into place and
we'll get rid of all those silly old
religious or metaphysical ideas
and we'll turn to just science by itself
and that will solve things for us
the name of that by the way is
positivism started in the 19th century
actually has its roots
in the enlightenment of the 18th century
and it's always been a crazy dream
without any true basis in reality or
history as a matter of fact
history shows us the opposite of that uh
as well as the fact that this this trope
gets repeated over and over again
science uh free reason do not actually
lead us necessarily to the truth or to
better social organization
as a matter of fact for many people they
open up before us an abyss
of unreason of irrationality
of meaninglessness of pure contingency
that
scares the living hell out of people
that makes them feel
things like nausea anxiety
those are typical existentialist ideas
that are being enunciated here right
in addition to this he talks about the
strong
ones who will bring their
strengths and their talents
and their power of their spirit and
ardor of their hearts to another field
and end by raising their free banner
against you you
being christ they won't just raise their
free banner against christ though
these are the people who want to achieve
something who want to do something
maybe even to make human beings happy or
to
deal with these sufferings or to advance
science
and their energies are going to lead
them into doing things and all this is
going to produce conflict
all of this is going to produce
meaninglessness
all of this is going to produce a
situation
in which the inquisitors the church
whoever else is lined up with them as
their colleagues
are going to have an opportunity he says
that
after going through all of that people
are going to come to us
and say we want to be happy
and we'll convince them that they will
only become free when they resign their
freedom
to us and submit to us
he says they will be convinced we are
right they will remember to what horrors
of slavery and confusion
your freedom led them freedom free
reason and science will lead them into
such a maze
confront them with such miracles and
insoluble mysteries
that some of them unruly and ferocious
will exterminate themselves
others unruly but feeble will
exterminate each other
the remaining third feeble and wretched
will crawl to our feet and cry out to us
yes you were right save us from
ourselves
and that will be the time when the grand
inquisitor and everything that he stands
for
is able to take over a new regime will
come into being
they will in fact have the power not
only of caesar
but of you could say a world empire
and be able to for the first time make
human beings
happy bring all of them onto one page
satisfy this desire for universality
that has not been realized at any point
in history
and that christ by assuming power in the
third temptation could according to the
grand inquisitor
have actually realized for humanity but
failed to do so so when humanity gives
up their freedom
to the rulers or one rule
or however you want to frame it this new
regime they will then
make human beings happy at the expense
of course
of freedom
you